hey guys it's Rob today I'm going to
show you how to make the origami swan
this was originally designed by Robert
Jade Lang it's a really nice Swan I
would say it's a beginner model but if
you haven't seen my origami crane
tutorial I would check it out click on
this link here and try that one first
because there are some similar folds
involved with making the Swan except you
don't have to make a bird base to
complete this one what you're going to
need is just a piece of white printer
paper if you have a white piece of
origami paper I would recommend that
because the swans are white so once you
have a piece of paper are you ready to
begin to make the origami swan we need a
piece of square paper so what we're
going to do with printer paper is take
this corner and fold it across so that
the top edge is aligned with the left
side edge once it's neatly lined up make
a crease and then you could remove the
excess paper by either tearing it or
cutting it's up to you when you do that
you'll have a piece of paper that looks
like this and when you open it you'll
see the paper is square and you also
have this diagonal fold just rotate the
paper until that fol is now vertically
positioned just like that we're going to
take the bottom two edges now and fold
them directly on to the midline there so
just take the edge fold it inwards and
once it's neatly lined up on that middle
crease just make a crease on the outside
here and then you could do the same with
the left edge so just take it and fold
it inwards
so when you're done you should have
something that resembles a kite if you
look at the top of the model you'll see
that we have a triangle here and the
base of the triangle goes from corner to
corner along these two edges here so we
want to crease the top of the model down
backwards along that line there until it
lies flush now it's a little easier to
do it when you flip the model over and
then you can pull upwards on the tip of
the model until you see this fold line
up with those two edges from corner to
corner you also want to make sure that
the tip of the triangle lines up with
the vertical midline once you have it
just like that then you can make a
crease along the bottom just like that
so your model should look like this now
so you want to hold it with this
triangle facing towards you just like I
am and we're going to take the tip of
the triangle again and we're going to
fold it down right here to this new
crease that we formed directly in the
middle take the tip of the triangle and
fold it down till it lines up with the
very bottom then you can make a crease
along the top
now we're going to take this edge and
align it with the bottom edge and to do
that we take this tip and we're going to
pull it down until you see this line
this crease align with the bottom edge
of the model the very bottom edge like
that so now you'll see how it's lining
up make a crease along the top now then
we're going to take the entire model and
we're going to fold it in half by Valley
folding it and Valley fold means that
you take it and you fold it upwards on
that midline crease that goes throughout
the model so take it and fold the model
in half like this and as you'll see it
might not want to go that way so just
push downwards in the middle like that
until you can fold it completely in half
make a crease along the edge just like
that now this is going to be the tail of
the Swan and this part is going to be
the head we're going to bring the tail
downwards just a little bit like that so
it's not completely flush with the top
and as you'll see when you do that it
kind of gets tucked in words to the
center so bring it down maybe like a
centimeter or about the width of your
pinky that's fine it doesn't really
matter and then you can make a crease
here so that it stays that way just like
that now we're going to take these two
bottom edges here and we're going to
fold them up until they meet the top of
the model so it's probably easier to set
it down on the table take it and fold it
up so that it lines up with the top of
the model and then make a crease all the
way across the bottom just like that and
you might need to flatten this part out
a little bit too so just push down on it
flip the model over and do the same with
this edge
okay so now what we're going to do is
we're going to take the tip here and
we're going to join it up with the tip
of the tail so just fold the model in
half like this you might just need to
round it off join the two tips up and
make a crease on the end so now when you
unfold it you'll see that we have a
crease there I'm just going to draw on
it so that you can see it a little
easier on both sides now we're going to
Valley fold the model from this point
here to the top of that crease so again
let me just draw on it so you can see
that Valley fold that we're going to
making and remember Valley fold means
that we're folding upwards along that
line so we're going to be folding
upwards along this line and also along
that line now it's easy to do this all
you need to do is to take you could take
the entire model like this and fold it
from this point to that point and when
you do that if you draw these lines on
both sides it's easier because when you
fold it hey guess what look I could see
that line I know I'm folding along the
right line so just make a crease just
like that and then you could unfold it
flip the model over and do the same
going this way
so now you'll see that we made two
valley folds now what we're going to do
is we're going to do an outside reverse
fold along these creases here so to do
that what we're going to do is we're
going to look at the bottom of the model
like this and you see this point here at
the corner we're going to pop that
inside out so what we're going to do is
we're going to push on this point here
like this you see how I popped it inside
out this is going to start folding
backwards like that and now we're going
to fold along these two Valley folds
that we made like that and at the same
time you want to push in the middle here
so that these two edges are brought
together so you should be able to kind
of flatten the model out now so that you
have something that looks like this so
the outside reverse fold is kind of like
popping it inside out like this and then
flattening it the inside reverse fold is
the same fold that we did when making
the head and tail of the origami crane
so if you've made the crane you know
exactly what I'm talking about it's just
like this so we're going to take our
model and a way that we could do that a
little easier is to first take the
bottom edge here fold it backwards like
this until it's lying directly on top of
the back of the Swan so once it's right
about there make a crease here then you
could unfold it and now you'll see that
crease right there
open these two edges and push here so
that you're kind of trying to get this
midline to lay on top of the back just
like that and then you're going to just
crease these two edges together
and make a crease on the outside here
now we're going to make the head and the
beak of the origami swan so to do that
take half of the portion here of the
neck and fold it towards you like that
now we're going to take the tip and fold
it inwards about the length of the first
portion of your thumb here so if you
want to fold it about that that amount
that's good it's really up to you and
then once you do that we're going to
fold a little bit of it back upward so
that there's some overhanging and the
amount that's overhanging is going to be
the the beak of your Swan so it's up to
you exactly how much you want I'm going
to put it about right there and then
what you're going to do is close this
portion of the neck back up and you also
want this beak portion to fold in half
as well so close that back up like that
and now we're also going to do another
inside reverse fold of the neck probably
about halfway so what you want to do is
you want to take this bottom edge here
and you're going to fold it up until
it's perpendicular with the back of the
Swan just like that so you don't want it
down like that you want it perpendicular
so it should cross with the back of the
Swan like that then you make a crease
right about there should be fun and then
you're going to unfold it and then
you're going to do another inside
reverse fold here along that V that you
should see so just tuck this in words
like that
and now you're going to have to bend the
beak the other way with these two edges
so it should look something like this
and now to complete the head of the
origami swan we're going to do an
outside reverse fold of this portion
here just like we did for the bottom
portion here so to do that again we're
going to make a crease like this and
this part is completely up to you what
the angle you want for the head so fold
it like that and then unfold it open
these two edges like that and then fold
downwards on the head like this crease
it here along the back and you also want
to make sure that this beak is creased
downwards now like that so it should
look something like this and now all you
have to do is to fold down the wings a
little bit now this again is up to you
on how you want to do it I like to take
this edge fold it down so that it joins
with this edge make a crease do the same
with the other side and then also we
have these two triangles sticking up we
could just fold those down a little bit
also open the end of it by kind of
tugging on it and you can push down on
this point if you like and there you go
you have completed your origami swan